hey this is ryan at movieclips I'm here
with Jon Favreau sir
it's a pleasure writer director of chef
among many other wonderful films we're
gonna do a rapid-fire questionnaire okay
and just first thing that comes to mind
tomato we're sorry tomato yeah that was
a softball sir
you're a steak or burger stay taxi
driver a regent was lying but burger
like better but I said it was like who's
like you know my if I found the Holy
Grail well yeah I mean it's the kind of
thing like you think a good burger
I actually prefer it can't be beaten
taxi driver a Raging Bull start with the
hard ones all right jingle for the
restaurant wise Nobu or Matsuhisa
Matsuhisa
Cowboys are aliens Cowboys new hope or
Empire you know Prime member spareribs
primary that's Paris for the Hulk I
wanted to take it easy this which is all
it has to go by that yeah it's that I'm
assuming it means the comics I would go
through the help okay CGI or practical
effects uh it's been practical practical
I've noticed yeah yeah I've been working
out so I don't you know times are
changing there's a jungle book we own
the real animals really no we can't get
out of talking bear that's what I'll try
if you know any I'll go back to
practical foggy Nelson are happy Hogan
happy Hogan LA or New York oh man
tough one right I know but now I'm here
for 20 years of my family's old Calif
California my kids are from LA New York
so what I take from that is that you
you're not crazy about your kids yeah
freaks and geeks are undeclared for free
CDs books are TV TV would you rather
live only under water or only in outer
space only under water would you rather
have forks or spoons four hands four
hands books film or digital digital Iron
Man or Iron Chef Iron Man Vince Vaughn
funny or funniest he's pretty damn funny
I'll go funniest puppets or marionettes
puppets Vince Vaughn had a different
answer he was not here he won't even do
that what do you do this for he did for
the internship Diddy yeah so that'll
give you guys something to talk about
huh well google improper stand-up improv
deep dish or thin slice man you get me a
lot of trouble here I lived in Chicago
for four years we did research we knew
that this one
could be it's hard I gotta go thin
though thin slice if you were forced to
recast one of these movies that you've
made would you you're asking me what man
I'd make love to no good honestly you
can answer that I'm saving my bad you
can you can answer it that way as well
just don't try anyway would you rather
recast Will Ferrell as a night long
co-star would you rather recast Will
Ferrell as Iron Man or Robert Downey jr.
is elf
Robert engineer's elf just to see what
happens it'd be good movie it would be
if you're really good movie Blazing
Saddles are bad news exhales okay sports
or films sports your foods foods these
were not all written by me we're all
written now dad knows we should sports
your foods everybody was I think it was
it was supposed to be fortress bones and
um someone played a joke on made a job
for your hands but you're uh you've got
this Lex yeah yeah no that's I'm forever
you also have a good grace now at the
forks whispers yeah I know it's no hands
what is this word this is this is four
feet four feet
sports or foods please Subway sandwiches
all right great Netflix or Hulu Netflix
YouTube or dailymotion YouTube Boulevard
transfer miles Finch miles Finch
no matter how good go he says now if you
said tyrion lanister miles Finch that
would be a tough one I'd love to see
those two in a room together that's a
battle I never have which makes me
suspicious xbox or playstation xbox
Clippers her Lakers Lakers Mets or
Yankees Mets if you had to have a pet
animal would you rather have a monkey
tiger which is good for Jungle Book
a monkey all right of course a talking
monkey no really three kids already
that's like that's for that going on Jon
Favreau everybody that was it yeah
painless well I just got scoped but it
wasn't as bad as I thought well I'm
upset to hear the thing that you thought
it was gonna be bad but I'm glad it was
not as bad it was challenging though
thoughtful good I'm glad
good good mental calisthenics good John
thank you so much everybody
go see chef it's a wonderful wonderful
movie and John is great in it and until
next time comment below and give you
love - Jon Favreau thank you for
watching